we are rolling these marbles might seem
like toys but they're actually internet
celebrities with a dedicated fan base
gaining over 140 million views on
YouTube wow what a move by Rojo Uno
shooting by for the gold step aside
Formula 1 this is marble
racing
behind the doors of this Warehouse a
group of people are working hard to keep
a world of marbles alive some of the
world's most exciting marble races are
created under the guidance of these two
brothers together they've embarked on a
journey that's unlike any other the wait
is finally over for the most prestigious
event in all of marble Athletics marble
League
2023 is here we made around 5 00 races
in the past 8 years wait a sec 500
marble races that's quite an adventure
I'd say it's a marbulous
adventure okay I'm sorry I couldn't
resist marble races are like Formula 1
races but with marbles there's a circuit
teams competing against each other and
all sorts of marble fans cheering from
all around the
world streaking down it's all about that
last little push and that last little
push is what made all the difference on
the near Lane for team Momo here's our
team there's my brother yella he's the
genius mind behind the design and build
of nearly every new racetrack that's me
Dion I come up with the concept create
scenery choose color combinations and
think about fun shots or scenes this is
our editing team it's yell and c and
most importantly Greg woods from IA us
he does the commentary oh and they've
exited it this is going to be very close
The Savage Speeders held on they did
another important figure for yellow
Marin is Mos filos he's from Greece from
aans and he makes the music does the
audio and he does a lot of other
tasks and finally there's our father
Pete who recently retired and helps us
with mostly
everything so guys why marbles we all
grew up with marbles our parents play
with them our grandparents and we all
Shar the universal love for marbles
evoking our childhood memories growing
up with autism yell loved his collection
of marbles and could spend hours just
placing them in perfect rows on his
bedroom floor I like mares because of
the colors and their movement I remember
as a kid spending the entire day laying
down my marbles collection on the floor
and trying to find out if one was faster
than the others as I grew up I started
building simple tracks using op I found
at home in 2006 he wanted to film his
marble races so he started his YouTube
channel yellow Marin in 2015 I asked
yell do you want to make a living out of
your
passion mty Maniacs a good launch out of
the gate but the hazers respond well and
stretch the lead they'll cruise to a
victory and hold on that's a new marble
League record in the pandemic around
2020 it got viral we came up with the
Olympic Games for marbles we were called
by John Oliver and he asked us to
sponsor the marble Olympics at that time
our Channel took a flight the number of
fans kept growing and growing yell and
Dion's project got featured on Last Week
Tonight on HBO they also have
merchandise for each marble team and
even have their own video game for me
the most interesting part is uh to be
creative and think about the scenery but
also new Concepts some fun elements
details like marble streakers or that
was yellow's idea that's that was not my
idea lers fans are too happy for some
reason they've thrown stuff onto the
track get a quick disruption here people
are going to clean that up referees and
security guards moving in front of the
lmer fans it can be a difficult uh
because you need to uh be sure that
every M has the same chance to win
sometimes you need to uh find tune
something uh to make uh the balance or
to avoid that the same Mar will win over
and over again keep in mind that it
takes more than 2 weeks to come up with
the marble race video concept to build
it film it edit it and publish it for
our fans once we stay a complex ceremony
it took 2 days to film
[Music]
it the marble run Community is very
passionate and extremely invested in
each race it created uh whole
communities around marble teams fans
were were rooting for one special marble
it's really
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing the fan Community is very
important sometimes we do a poll for
names or marble team or some ideas from
the sounds we use in our videos The
Magic of marble racing is that it feels
like a competition so you pick a marble
and you follow it from the beginning to
the end I think it's human to have that
that feeling for competition and I think
that's the magic of it there Advantage
is growing their Fort marble is ahead of
everyone else crazy cat size will cruise
to a gold so Dion could you introduce us
to one of your favorite marbles this is
Momo one of our most uh fa famous
marbles uh we had a a fidget spinner
event and uh a piece broke off so he got
wounded oh there you can see it a big
chunk came off oh my goodness that is a
great concern to them there were so many
fans who were messaging us came with
questions about injury updates here you
can see the piece that broke off now
it's glued again so you can see the
stitches is it difficult coming up with
new ideas for every race my YouTube is
nle keeping so you have to keep up with
the tempo come up with new videos and
everything it never stops but we love
doing it I came up with the idea to to
go to a large Sand Hill and make a very
long sand track and let M race through
them red eye but wow
snowy gets by just before the Finish
Line I have a lot of respect for my
brother yell he's very independent uh
he's creative he takes risk and uh look
where he is now he's doing a very good
job and he's a great inspiration for a
lot of people with Autism it seems that
yella and Dion won't be giving up their
passion project just yet I'm happy when
people watch my videos I love it yellow
mun uh represents for me the
lighthearted fun videos that distract
you from the reality in real life I
really love to see people enjoying the
videos we are very humble that we can't
give this to people but it is clementin
and the old Rangers who have unseated
the home team and have climbed their own
Mountain to the peak of marbula 1 they
are your Championship
[Music]
winners